Hello, ma'am.
I'm sorry to do this here at work for you,
but I'm here to inform you
that you have been let go of your position as a teacher
here at the school, and you are also under arrest.
What? Why?
Well, you are considered a threat to children,
and you have exposed all of these children in your class
to pornography. What?
I have never done that. I can see where the confusion has come from,
but as you know, we do have new laws that have just been passed,
and these new laws now categorize all LGBTQ relationships
as pornographic. And if you expose children to those relationships,
you are exposing children to pornography. What?
I just have a photo of us at my desk,
and honestly, we look like we're friends.
We're not doing anything romantic in that photo.
If this was a week ago, then, yes,
you would be right. However,
the new laws do state that it is inappropriate.
Children are only allowed to know that men and women can be together,
nothing else. Okay,
well, I'll take the photo down, then.
I'm sorry, ma'am,
but the damage has already been done.
The kids have already seen the photo.
And plus, let's not even get started on your social media.
It's all over all of your social medias
that you are supposedly a lesbian.
And,
yeah, we just.
That's also very inappropriate.
Children cannot see that. So
I am sorry to say that you
Are under arrest for sex crimes against children.
This is ridiculous. I'm just living my life and existing.
And not to alarm you or anything,
but here in the state of Florida,
sex crimes against children do carry a maximum penalty of death.
This is absurd. I haven't hurt anybody.
Sorry, ma'am. That's just how it is.